[Music]
what is up everybody its Anna Mack here
for anime outpour and welcome to another
attack on Titan video in this video we
will be talking about the ninth and
final Titan shifter the Warhammer
tightened the only Titan shifters that
we still haven't seen even though we
first learned about the Warhammer Titan
back in Chapter 95 as of chapter 100 we
still haven't seen this shifter appear
in the manga and in this video I will be
discussing some theories about why we
still haven't seen the Warhammer Titan
and whether we've actually been lied to
this entire time about who the Warhammer
Titan truly is by the way if you're
wondering where my attack on Titan
chapter 100 review is it was taken down
due to a false copyright claim from
Kodansha Japan I am fighting this false
claim right now and I hope the video
will be back up soon there is no way
that Kodansha or any other company owns
my thoughts and my commentary on a
chapter of a manga thank you all for the
support you've shown for the chapter
reviews I didn't realize how much you
guys enjoyed them each month until this
video was taken down and so many of you
voiced your support thank you all it
really means a lot to me and if you
could please do me a favor follow us on
twitter at anime uproar in case
something like this ever happens again
because that is the best way for us to
inform you on what's going on we are now
also posting on instagram daily so if
you prefer to use instagram you can
follow us there as well at anime up road
both links will be right there in the
description as always this video will
contain attack on Titan manga spoilers
up to the latest chapters so proceed
with caution as of right now we have
been told that the possessor of the
Warhammer Titan is the head of the Tiber
royal family Willy Tiber it is worth
noting that the chapter where we are
first told this information by Zeke is
chapter 95 and the title of this chapter
is osots key or liar
member that for later the reason I am
making this video is largely because of
what happened at the end of chapter 100
of the manga as Willy Tiber is holding a
big speech at the festival in the
liberia internment zone and talking
about uniting the whole world against
their common enemy Aaron and the LD ins
on Paradise Island and as he declares
war on Aaron and his comrades and
transforms into a Titan bursts out from
the building right above the stage and
literally rips willy Tiber
in half in front of everyone this was a
major shocker and there are a few
options for what could happen next let's
say that Willy simply sacrificed himself
for his cause and Eden really killed him
we know that Willy knew that Aaron's
attack was coming but maybe he still
decided to hold the speech because he
knew that if Aaron kills him in front of
everyone then the entire world would
start hating Adam and everyone would
want to unite against the audience of
parodies but if Willy really is dead if
he cannot somehow use the Warhammer
Titan power to recover from being
literally torn in half then we have to
ask ourselves an important question
would Willie Tiber really risk losing
the Warhammer Titan power or even have
Aaron consume his spinal fluid and take
the Warhammer Titan power from him just
to get the world to hate in it if Willie
really did this it would not be a very
smart move let's remember that the LD
ins of parodies already hold the
founding Titan the attack Titan and the
Colossus Titan powers and the female
Titan is currently out of commission
would the Tiber is really risk losing
the Warhammer Titan to Aaron as well I
find this highly unlikely I find it much
more likely that if Willie Tiber is
really dead then he was never the
Warhammer Titan in the first place the
final Titan shifter must be someone else
entirely someone who is still hiding in
the shadows
and if this was the case then it would
make sense why we haven't seen Willie
transform into the Warhammer Titan yet
and if this was the case then it would
also make sense for willing to sacrifice
himself if Willie doesn't have the
Warhammer Titan power than his death
isn't nearly as much of a loss for the
timers as it would be if they just
handed another Titan shifter to the
enemy this is the point where we need to
remember that chapter 95 is called liar
this is the chapter in which we first
learned that the Tiber family possesses
the Warhammer Titan but what if Zeek the
one who told us this information was the
liar here
what if Zeek lied about Willie
possessing the Warhammer Titan in order
to facilitate the plan for Willie to
publicly sacrifice himself and unite the
world against Adam and the LD ins on
parodies and if Willie Tiber was not the
Warhammer tightened the final Titan
shifter the big question is who and
where is the Warhammer Titan
does another member of the Tiber family
possess the Warhammer Titan but their
identity is being kept secret to prevent
someone from trying to steal the final
Titan shifters power away from the
typers or did the Tiber family lose the
Warhammer Titan at some point in the
past did someone steal it from them like
the owl
Ehren Kruger stole the attack Titan this
would mean that the timers have been
lying about possessing the Warhammer
Titan in order to keep their power and
influence over Marlay even though they
actually lost it sometime in the past
there is one thing that has always
bothered me
and it's this why did Marlay decide to
send any Reiner Marcel and Berthold to
parties and ordered them to breach the
walls even though the typers knew about
the Kings vow of pacifism meaning that
the typers knew that the King behind the
walls was not a threat to Marlay and
would not become a threat in the future
why would they send
for Titan shifters behind the walls and
risk losing these four incredibly
important assets if there was no threat
to speak of however if the Tigers did in
fact lose the Warhammer Titan power at
some point in the past and they were
trying to keep this fact hidden then
that would explain why the Tiber family
wanted to take the founding Titan even
though they knew that the King inside
the walls was not a threat
the Tiber x' would have known that
sooner or later someone would find out
that they lost the Warhammer
Titan and before that happened they
wanted to get their hands on the
founding Titan and that's because they
would want to preserve their position as
the secret rulers of Marlay if the truth
came out that the Tiber x' did not have
the Warhammer Titan then why would Marly
continue to accept the authority of the
timers in my video on the secret power
of the Warhammer Titan I argued that the
reason why the Tiber family was allowed
to live freely in Marly despite being LD
ins was because Marla was afraid of the
power of the Warhammer Titan in fact we
later learned that the Tiber family is
secretly ruling Marlay from behind the
scenes which would again suggest that
the Warhammer Titans power was massive
enough to convince them our land
officials that it was better to accept
the authority of the Pipers than face
the wrath of the Warhammer Titan if you
want to learn more about my theory about
the secret power of the Warhammer Titan
and how this shifter could be so
powerful that the army of Marly would be
afraid of it feel free to check out the
full video link in the description but
if Marlay only tolerated the authority
of the Tiber family because the terrible
power of the Warhammer Titan kept them
in check if it was suddenly reveal that
the typers didn't have the Warhammer
Titan power anymore that would probably
be the end of the Tiber family they
would be treated just like any other
ldiots in Marlay or perhaps even worse
they might be killed so that they could
never pose a threat to Marlay again in
this case it would make perfect sense
for the Tigers to risk everything in
order to get their hands on the founding
titan with the coordinate in their
possession the Tigers could still remain
dominant and they could still keep the
army of Marlay in check
even without the Warhammer Titan if this
theory is true and the Tigers no longer
possess the Warhammer Titan power and
that is why they were so desperate to
get their hands on the founding Titan
then the question becomes where is the
Warhammer Titan now does another LD and
on the continent secretly possess this
power perhaps a member of the LVN
restorationist or has the Warhammer
Titan power been smuggled onto the
island of parodies just like the attack
Titan was taken to the island by Aaron
Kruger could the true Warhammer Titan be
someone we already know but we just
don't realize it yet if this is the case
then ISA Yama has fooled us all yet
again and we are in for another massive
twist in the story very soon perhaps as
soon as chapter 101 nevertheless this is
just a theory at this point and there
are other possibilities for what could
happen next that also need to be
mentioned in the case that Willie wasn't
lying and he really does have the
Warhammer Titan power then either he
could somehow use it to regenerate his
body and survive although his body was
drastically damaged by Aaron so this
might be a bit of a stretch but in that
case we will finally see the Warhammer
Titan in action as Willy faces off
against Aaron's attack Titan in an epic
showdown inside Lee Barry o or perhaps
Aaron will consume Willie spinal fluid
and take the Warhammer Titan power for
himself this would mean that Aaron would
have three Titan powers in one body the
attack Titan the founding Titan and the
Warhammer Titan and that would make him
a nearly unstoppable force we still
don't know what the power of the
Warhammer Titan is but I'm willing to
bet that it will be very unique and very
powerful definitely powerful enough to
convince the entire male military that
it would be better not to mess with the
timer's lastly there is one more option
for what could happen next in the attack
on Titan manga as I said before in
Chapter 95 Zeke was the one who told us
about the Warhammer Titan and throughout
these last few chapters we have gotten
brief glimpses of Zeke that make me
think that he is definitely up to
something the fact that he seemed to
encourage Reiner to go and meet secretly
with Aaron and the fact that he was not
led into the same trap as peak and Porco
seemed to hint that he may have a secret
plan what if the comrade that Aaron was
sending letters to with vocals help was
not anyone from parodies what if it was
Zeke Zeke had promised to return to
Paradise and save his half-brother Aaron
earlier on in the manga so did the two
of them meet at some point during the
time skip and come up with a plan to end
the suffering of all ldiots and was
willy Tiber a part of this plan or was
he a victim of it when I was looking at
how Willy was portraying Aaron during
his speech at the festival as this
terrible evil villain and a threat to
the entire world that everyone must
unite against I couldn't help but think
of the zero Requiem in Col Geass I
mentioned this in my initial review of
the chapter but Willy was trying to
focus the world's hatred on Aaron and he
wanted the world to unite against him
and this includes those LD ins who are
in Marlay and it was almost as if the
end goal was that when Aaron this
supposedly evil villain is killed that
everyone can rejoice and live together
in peace if this theory is on the right
track and we are looking at a zero
Requiem type of scenario then we might
be looking at Aaron either dying or
faking his own death in the near future
in order to create a
world a world where LD ins and everyone
else can live in peace after the
so-called evil LD ins like Aaron have
been eliminated now this might sound
corny but I personally am a sucker for
happy endings and I really don't want to
see characters like Eren Mikasa Armin or
Levi die
Sasha either I love Sasha so I am still
hoping for some sort of happy ending
where a cure for Amir's curse is found
and they all survive but we know that
attack on titan is a mature and sad
story where many important characters
have already died and in the past
isayama
also hinted at a tragic ending so I fear
we may be heading in that direction at
any rate let me know what you guys think
did Willy Tiber fool us all and is the
Warhammer Titans still out there
somewhere does another member of the
Tiber family have it or was it stolen
from the Tiber family at some point in
the past if Willy really does have the
Warhammer Titan power is he going to
somehow save himself by transforming or
is Aaron going to consume his spinal
fluid and take the more hammertime power
for himself finally what do you think is
happening with Zeke our Zeke and Eden
working together on a secret plan that
is about to come together let me know
all your thoughts down in the comments a
big thank you to at this user is alive
for allowing me to use his awesome fan
art of Willy Tiber in the thumbnail feel
free to check out his Instagram add this
user is alive link in the description
also remember to follow us at anime
uproar on twitter and on instagram and
if you enjoyed this video be sure to
leave a like to let me know if you are
new to the channel don't forget to
subscribe and hit that notification bell
as always thank you all so much for
watching thank you for all the support
and until next time see us space cowboys
you
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]